vingt-quatre heures après l'incendié la
fumée témoigne toujours de l'ampleur du
sinistre
les propriétaires étaient absents hier
après midi lorsque les flammes ont
ravagé des hectares de céréales
alentours et une partie des bâtiments de
cette ancienne exploitation agricole en
rentrant à la maison en début de soirée
patrick françois et sa soeur chantal
n'ont pu que constater le désastre
il en a vu que que lang arrêté par terre
afin que toutes et tous brûler quoi on a
eu tous et toutes étaient aussi dans les
saules tout ça ç'a failli brûler la
maison ancienne ferme quoi très
mauvaises odeurs et très bonne surprise
une enquête est en cours pour ce énième
incendie de la semaine car des témoins
parlent de l'inconscience d'un voisin
qui aurait brûlé des détritus à quelques
centaines de mètres les pompiers
surchargés de travail réclament donc la
vigilance de tous depuis le 24 juin nous
avons réalisé 170 cette intervention et
le feu à parcourir peu à peu près dit un
peu plus de 1000 hectares
là effectivement il faut quatre villes
vigilant donc il est interdit de faire
brûler des détritus des végétaux il ya
des déchetteries pour ça donc voilà donc
il faut absolument ne pas utiliser les
fenu autres causes de ces feux régulier
le passage des moissonneuses batteuses
dans des champs de céréales frappée par
la sécheresse
beaucoup d'agriculteurs prennent des
précautions d'usagé en installant une
réserve d'eau à proximité immédiate de
la parcelle moissonnée mais certains
admettre qu'il faudra peut-être
travailler différemment dans les
prochains jours on pourrait certainement
ainsi de s'adapter faire la nuit
notamment
on en ressort que la nuit la paille est
beaucoup plus belle
on arrive à conserver bien mieux la
paille mais le fait est que la météo et
là on en profite pendant que la météo
est belle et d'en faire un maximum
pendant pendant ce créneau de météo quoi
la semaine prochaine des températures
supérieures à 35 degrés sont attendues
en certains points de la région
les pompiers ne sont pas prêts de chômer